you got Maids medical assistance in
dying as a program in Canada 2016.
Supreme Court says it's unconstitutional
to deny medical assistance in dying to
the terminally ill liberal government
comes in and says okay well we're going
to enact legislation that we're going to
amend the criminal code we're going to
allow for it
um and at the time I think it was on
basically unsolicited it was a liberal
Member of Parliament said well we don't
want to discriminate against the
mentally ill we want to allow the
mentally ill people who are men who are
by legal definition incapable of consent
when it comes to certain judicial acts
this is physically painful
it's going to get worse we don't want to
let we don't want to deny them the
constitutional right to end their own
lives so we're going to allow mentally
ill people to commit suicide sorry to
medical assistance in dying euthanasia
or as it was once called a project
action I think